The Joe Rogan Experience speaking of
Shame this uh now I'm just getting this
is the per you and I are the perfect
people to talk about this crypto because
we're scientist because we are
economists yes we have strong opinions
and no information which is a great
combination when you're dealing with the
fact that people have lost billions and
billions of dollars but what so Jamie's
been filling me in on this over the
weekend and he also is an economist yeah
is our go-to expert I just find
interesting links and say hey check this
out
which is fine yeah that's journalism
yeah and uh as a journalist what's your
conclusion
it seems like
but here's the thing
if you're running any kind of currency
operation and you're involved in a
polyamorous relationship with seven
other people I gotta think you're wacky
nine nine other people ten ten of the
people ten total what do they do they
just were polyamorous living in a house
together all live together in the same
place in the Bahamas and then I'll just
bang each other hey
so wait set this up because you're kind
of starting in the middle what are we
talking about here fun
talk about a lot of fun in the Bahamas
yeah with billions of dollars other
people's money
I should call that a tax Haven tax Haven
yeah so this fella was running this
Exchange
and um
they also had tokens someone explained
it someone did a really good job of
explaining it and uh we could play that
video but it might take too much time
it's like a 12 minute video but he was
explaining how these tokens are like
they're essentially unregulated but it
it's almost like you're owning stock and
it's very or almost like owning coin
it's very confusing but uh it's one of
those classic examples of people try to
cash in
and then the whole thing came down yeah
it's from Ponzi scheme has been thrown
around yeah quite a lot well there's not
just that there seems to be money
missing like a lot of money missing that
got moved from one Corporation to a
sister Corporation so this is FTX right
yes yeah and
um apparently they reached out to
coinbase I read that they reached out to
coinbase and coinbase is like we can't
help you this looks bad like what's
going on over here and then now it's
sort of imminently collapsing and tons
of people have invested tons of money
over there and they don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on people are trying to
pull their money out by buying nfts for
ridiculous amounts of money in the
Bahamas because apparently people in the
Bahamas still have access to the the
thing to to The Exchange is that the
case yep yep then they would imagine
that they're reaching out to the person
then buying this nft that would have
yesterday been worth nine dollars and I
was bought for like 10 million right to
then make like a currency exchange like
you can keep ten percent of that yeah
they jack up the value of it right right
so they basically say look I'm gonna buy
your nft for 10 million dollars I'm
gonna give you a million dollars and
then you give me the nine back and so
that's how they're exchanging money and
trying to just draw it out of this
account right who knows how that's going
to work out right whether people are
going to be like [ __ ] you look at your
money you're like how's that work right
but all of it is run by this guy who
they were in the middle of
profiling him
who who sent me this I did like Michael
Lewis is the guy's name he's the writer
of like Moneyball and The Big Short many
books and so he was in the middle of
profiling this guy when everything
collapsed which is wild right
that is very wild wild yeah like what
are the odds that that happens at the
exact same time because this guy was
this Wonder kid who uh had developed
this thing was worth 15 billion dollars
and was like wearing pajamas and [ __ ]
like one of those like eccentric cats
didn't all the crypto kind of take a big
massive hit though I think all of crypto
did take a big massive hit but I think
this is a lot crazier than that right
this isn't just like crypto took a hit
everybody's business is [ __ ] this is
like Shenanigans so like some high level
like serious shenanigans
the most generous billionaire yeah
that's part of this so they're like yeah
this has been unfolding like in real
time on Twitter which has been an
interesting place to be for the last few
weeks but uh this guy apparently during
this used a PR I don't know if this
would be a scheme but a YouTuber it was
paid to make this piece about him and
the way he gives away money
which adds to
I wouldn't want people to know we wanted
people to know he's a good guy correct
he reached out to Elon apparently while
Elon was buying Twitter and offered to
chip in 3 billion and he said Elon said
that said his [ __ ] meter off because
like elon's a serious dude you say he's
like this guy's 3 million liquid or a
billion rather 3 billion liquid like
does he have that money right that's a
lot of money right say like we're gonna
buy Twitter for 44. I'm in for three
right three billion right that's a crazy
amount of money yeah and so Elon said
that said his [ __ ] meter off right
because like what where do you get the
three billion yeah you can't just say
that to that guy I was like oh cool he's
not gonna just say oh cool he's gonna
know basically what you can and can't
he's the [ __ ] he's the richest guy in
the world right understands money right
and he knows who really has that money
and who may be laundering well who might
be just kind of a crazy person who you
know is probably can't believe he's in
where he's at when you find stories
about him from before he was like the
world's youngest billionaire happened
super fast world richest person person
under 30 committed billions the vast
majority of his fortune to tackling the
most pressing problems facing the future
of humanity where did he's nice get his
money though click on that what are
those most pressing problems click on
that link what is that link up there
this is It's on Reddit off to hold on oh
it's on Reddit yeah
interesting
like I understand where Elon made his
money I think like all things he's
probably not all bad it just didn't work
out the way he thought it was going to
and it was for so long and he probably
thought I could get away with doing what
he was doing and he probably also
thought he was doing good so if he
really is like super charitable he
probably also thought that he was way
smarter than he was right because he's
under 30 and he's a billionaire already
he probably thinks he's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
could you imagine if you were worth 15
billion and you were 28. you would think
you're the [ __ ] you think you could do
whatever and also you're banging nine
people in the house together yeah I'd be
doing bad stuff that's too much money
for a 20 something year old you're not
playing by any rules anybody's rules
[ __ ] off yeah and I'm gonna give my
money away to everybody and I'm also
going to move 10 billion over here all
right New York Post is reporting this
stuff too okay cryptocurrency
billionaire broke the bank for Dems okay
so this might be real
so amid the Jubilation and gloating by
Joe Biden Chuck Schumer and Pals over
Democrats better than expected showing
in the midterms comes a disturbing story
that may explain something about how
they won such a curious election Biden's
second biggest donor cryptocurrency
billionaire wonderkind
winter kind or kind wonder wonder kind
Wonder kind Sam bankman fried is it
fried or for free freed yeah Sam bankman
freed AKA SPF I like that I saw his
business file for bankruptcy days after
the election but not before pumping 40
million into the Democratic party to
spend on get out the vote and other
shadowy ballot harvesting Mech Mechanics
for the midterms the shambolic that's a
new word what's that mean I don't know
what does that mean let's find out what
that means
I'm confused
Shaman like what do you think it means
shambolic maybe Shaman like chaotic
disorganizing chaotic disorganized
mismatch oh I would say yeah definitely
shambola gets a new word yeah 30 year
old whiz kid once said to have been
worth 16 billion had spent 10 million in
helping get Biden elected in 2020. sbf's
mother Stanford whoops uh Stanford law
professor Barbara freed also the
co-founder of left-wing political action
committee mind the gap which is raised a
reported 140 million to help Democrats
win elections through the same get out
the vote grift a more unlikely
billionaire you could not find and of
course his money was built on thin air a
math genius with poor social skills
SBF reportedly lived in a polycule A
polyamorous relationship with multiple
people in a luxury Penthouse with about
10 co-workers in the tax Haven of the
Bahamas where he where his collapsed
crypto exchange FDX was headquartered
wow this is bad this is crazy yeah it's
crazy that a person like that got to
where he was I mean new uh Reuters is
reporting that between now Reuters
excuse me is reporting that between 1
billion and 2 billion of customer funds
have vanished from FTX conveniently
after the Democrats safely spent his
money
at the very least this is a New York
Post Yeah at the very least it's the
same uh negligence and lack of due
diligence that the celebrities that
endorsed companies like this
uh didn't do you know what I mean it's
like well how could they know right if
you're a celebrity I'm just just like
play Devil's Advocate yeah if you're a
Matt Damon or whoever Kim Kardashian I
mean people are making money with
Bitcoin there's Bitcoin billionaires
there's coinbase which is apparently
doing very very well there's uh Bitcoins
that are sponsoring Sports they they
sponsor Arenas right they they name
Arenas after them actually I think they
have to change one of the Arenas this is
one of them yeah yeah oh it did which
one was it Miami Miami of course it's
Miami it's one of the Cocos yeah party
that's so main economy of that town so
how would they know well I knew I mean I
don't mean to say that but it's like I
always questioned it and I knew so how
come they didn't know maybe if they
turned off their greedy [ __ ] hat for
one second and asked some [ __ ]
questions about what's actually going on
they would have known been like what
actually is this but they didn't they
said oh he's offering me 30 million
dollars so I can endorse them that'll
make people believe in it more and
they'll invest in it and then we'll take
that money and and all your money that
you're hoping is going to turn into more
money when this thing blows up we'll
take that and fund the [ __ ]
Democratic fund a political party yeah
it's slippery it is definitely slippery
there's something weird that's what
happened there's something very weird
about it it's the same thing like what's
the cult again I keep forgetting what
they did what he did with the Seagram's
daughters they funneled all the money
into his little cult and with that money
he was able to get the Dalai Lama and a
couple other people that gave it
legitimacy and then other people going
like it must be legitimate if this
person's in it and they started giving
them all the money and all he was doing
doing was branding women and [ __ ]
them what did they think you was doing
though they thought he was doing this
self-help thing and empowering women and
and uh you know teaching them how to be
more uh rigorous very ignorant to this
cult oh it's incredible when I found out
I was involving Hollywood people I was
like yeah but yeah Dad gave up on the
the actress from Smallville there was a
few other people and but it was all over
the world it wasn't just LA and it was
based in Albany first of all that that's
how you know people are stupid because
if I'm not I'm not if you're buying into
a cult that's in Albany you're stupid
and then they went to Albany to attend
his little weekend retreat bad place to
live it's Albany it's a [ __ ]
people from Albany are mad at you right
now do you understand well they know I'm
right though it's a dump it's the
[ __ ] capital of the state of New York
son of a [ __ ] yeah I know and I it's uh
I don't know why it's a [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] dump but they did the
same exact thing that these crypto
people did specifically this kid freed
it's definitely not the Bahamas it's not
the Bahamas right like he got it right
yeah kid got it right he got the
billions like Bahamas yeah
that is a pretty wild thing to do though
to be living in a house banging all
these people you're working with raking
in billions funneling some of it to the
Democratic party doing all this
philanthropy work probably thinking
you're a [ __ ] Gem of a person yeah
until it all comes crashing down but if
it didn't come crashing down that's like
the Bernie Madoff thing if it wasn't for
the 2008 crash would Bernie Madoff been
able to keep that hustle going oh he was
so good at it he was so good oh he was
so good he used to show up at his
client's son's baseball games and answer
their phone calls and of course he did
he really was a good con artist of
course he did he showed great attention
to them so they didn't they didn't look
at the stealing hand
I mean but you know the Democratic party
should have done uh a little due
diligence been like what is this they
didn't ask questions either or not they
just took the money they took the money
right it's not their fault what the [ __ ]
are they supposed to do if this lady set
it up with her son and he's [ __ ]
funneling that money Yeehaw let's go
you'd have to go and do an audit on
their business and make sure it's
running right give me that money but I
don't care where you got it from I don't
know nothing yeah people come to see
your show how much of it is cocaine
money how much how many people are
coming to see Giannis Papas that are
secretly Coke dealers I I would say
probably zero percent more than one
maybe one yeah come on I've never done
100 man yeah out of all the shows you've
ever done yeah how many people paid for
your ticket and they were involved in
illegal activity that's different though
I'm not I'm not the government
we're just accepting a little money we
don't have time we're running a campaign
we're trying to overturn this Roe v Wade
[ __ ] yeah come on man we're trying
to codify well Roe v Wade we need money
that's what I love when they turned over
Roe v Wade the first thing they did is
give us money yeah give us more money we
need donations the only way we're gonna
fix this
yeah and then yeah no empirical uh says
that they used him like Greta thundberg
uh like Greta funberg the teenage Eco
evangelist SPF was manipulated into
serving a useful purpose isn't that kind
of editorializing though it could be
yeah exactly know what was going on
there in other words FB apps analytical
IQ and social ineptitude made him a
prime recruit for the cause of hijacking
capitalism to divert money to left-wing
causes whoa nerd sniped so the article
the article describes bankman Freed's
recruitment into the EA cult when he was
a young man at MIT as being nerd sniped
which is the practice of attracting
brain power by presenting problems as
puzzles wow EA is effective altruism wow
interesting